i thought i saw
an interesting one
mr ayantari
show me what you got
he uh lost the match here the other day
to
john sebastian christensen in um
he's playing the targe wow
didn't expect that
didn't expect that at all so i'm just
gonna play very very solid
bore him to death
there are actually a lot of um
very interesting sharp lines in this
opening
uh not this one though this one
generally leads to boring positions that
are very slightly better from whites
and it's generally a good choice if you
if you want to make your your life
i saw your your opponent's life
miserable okay so what's the story here
okay let's let's take another six nine
yeah i think we should take enough six
there was a [ __ ] by four there
maybe bishop like foreign better
actually
yeah i think bishop was better
huh that was that was a shame yeah no
no yeah not a4 and then bishop moves
i can take on d4 there was knight bishop
b6 though
then knight b6 queen b6 bishop 6 pf6
maybe that's what he wanted and it's not
completely clear but
nevertheless it was possibly
was possibly better i think here still
bishop b6 is going to be played
maybe i don't have that much
i actually don't have that much at all
bishop b6 queen b6
knight d4 rook 88
and i got nothing
i think the weakness of his king side is
not significant there
okay i'll go e4 instead then
95
okay let's uh
try and play for this positional idea of
trying to um claim that my knight could
one day
be stronger than his bishop
it seems seems a bit far-fetched to be
honest
even as the the author of the idea it
seems far-fetched
usually not a good sign okay i'll take
and then
i'll start the whole re-routing
operation
okay so far some good i can establish an
item d3 or
c4 i should be doing fine
okay we'll go g3 just to be safe
yeah rook h6 doesn't seem to do
all that much
f5
that's brave i don't know if it's any
good
i think the superior minor piece
the possible opening here of the
of the king side is quite favorable to
me
okay we'll go queen g2
it goes away and then try and double
rooks
okay this is gonna be a bit of a
scramble
very interesting
okay we'll uh no more time for talking
we gotta we gotta start working here
giving up this one would check but i do
think
that his king is the one that's gonna be
weaker here potentially
hopefully at least
if it takes on ca twice it'll take on h2
so i'm not worried about that okay
now i think i'll take
do i have anything good here
not g4 there's d2 which looks a bit
scary
okay i don't have time i don't have time
at all well i'm trapping his rook
that was fortunate didn't actually see
that
okay then i'm winning only question is
like if i can do it in time
yes the pawn is working
we'll take this one e7 take rookie three
and
good time no i was going to nc3 first
what is this okay
what
what how did i lose some time
i was pre-moving
what how did that happen
i thought i had plenty of time there
huh guess my internet is not ideal